[Music]
the world's leading superpowers are
locking horns game on here a trade war
between the united states and
china is here over the past 16 months
america and china have been trading
blows through tariffs on goods
we are looking at a reality that has you
know a 25 tariff on every single product
that would come in from china
the impact is being felt on industries
worldwide
but what is the story behind the america
china trade war
so the trade war what have you guys been
looking at the us doesn't like
that china is growing so fast and
set to overtake uh america as like the
biggest economy in the world if it
hasn't already by certain measures right
basically china and u.s are kind of
caught in this
race of imposing tariffs on each other
so u.s slaps a high tariff on certain
products and then china retaliates
it's multiple industries across multiple
markets it's huge
and i think right now would be a really
good time to look at what's happened
and how it could impact the world from
now on
at the economist we've been covering the
trade war extensively
sumaia keynes is our trade and
globalization editor based in washington
dc
how did this whole trade war kick off
how did this whole trade war start for a
long time there have been frustrations
that past
american administrations had with the
chinese
on the 2016 presidential campaign trail
you started to see some really
tough rhetoric we can't continue to
allow
china to rape our country and that's
what they're doing
and so he gets into office his united
states
trade representative that's the kind of
official trade negotiator
they're working on this big report so
they're essentially investigating
china's economic practices essentially
the question they're asking is
has china done anything that would
frustrate america's economic interests
and they find
surprise surprise yes how long a history
is there of
uh these complaints the u.s has about
china these concerns go back for a
really long time
and i think to understand them properly
you really need to go
way back to the expectations that people
had
when china was thinking about entering
the world trade organization
china's economic rise has been dramatic
in 1978
china's gdp at market prices was just
six percent of america's
last year it had grown to 66 when
considering local spending power
china has already overtaken america
this unprecedented growth began with
deng xiaoping
he started opening up china's economy to
the world in 1978
and the country quickly became the
world's factory
over the next decade exports as a share
of gdp
tripled and by 1988 15
of china's exports went to america
[Music]
the world trade organization opened its
doors to china in 2001
and it was america that ushered it in
bringing china into the wto is a win-win
decision it will protect our prosperity
and it will promote the right kind of
change in china
after joining the wto china became an
economic superpower
but people had expected the country to
also become more like a western
capitalist economy
that didn't happen america now claims
that china achieved its growth
by not playing fair are those claims
justified
to find out the answer i spoke with
david rennie he's our beijing bureau
chief
there's two ways in which china
certainly hasn't been playing fair
one way is just that china treats
chinese companies differently
so if you are a western business your
chinese competitor
not only has better market access but
maybe the land that it built its factory
on
was given for free maybe it got a giant
tax break
china just doesn't have a level playing
field there's then
the really dirty stuff stealing foreign
companies technology
if you ask chinese officials about the
accusation that china
is stealing its way to the top they'll
say well hang on america steals secrets
too
so why are you coming after us the
american government will tell you
sure they spy and they steal stuff but
never for commercial purposes
with donald trump's election in 2016
you had a president who actually set
about getting tough with china
once he was in office and we've never
really had that before
the trump administration has been using
tariffs or taxes on imported goods
to try to force the chinese to change
their ways
in july 2018 america imposed tariffs of
25
on 34 billion dollars worth of chinese
products
that almost doubled the average tariff
rate on chinese imports
from 3.8 percent to 6.7 percent
and it's american firms that have to pay
that tax
but with every increase from america
came an increase from china
since the start of the trade war china
has more than doubled its average tariff
rate
america's has tripled the fight has
become overtly political
because china's tariffs are hitting
president trump's voter base
many counties where trump won in the
2016 election were here
in the great plains and these are the
counties most affected by china's
tariffs
someone who knows all about the impact
tariffs are having beyond the data
is chad baum from the peterson institute
for international economics
he's been analyzing international trade
for decades but the trade war has put
his research in the spotlight
some people have referred to it as is my
world cup or my super bowl it's
something that i've been studying in the
background for 20 years and now all of a
sudden the world seems to be interested
in this
what role do terrorists play in in a
trade war tariffs are basically
a a tax but it's a tax that's only paid
for goods that are produced outside of
the country in a specific place
one of the things that china has done in
its tariffs is it's
imposed really high tariffs on american
exports of of soybeans
this is a huge product that farmers in
iowa and across the midwest grow only to
sell to china
so how are these tariffs and the trade
war
impacting the wider world economy i
think at some level
we're seeing the decisions
that businesses make be affected by this
nowadays they're not sure what markets
are going to be open to them
in the future and that's going to impact
their investment decisions the
international monetary fund the imf
they expect economic growth to be a lot
lower
in the future because of the tensions
are rising during the trade war the
global economy
is is slowing down and everybody's
increasingly concerned about that
as things stand now a ceasefire in the
trade war could be drawing near
the two leaders are hoping to agree on a
phase one deal soon
which could mean some tariffs being
lifted the trump administration wants
china to buy more american produce
and tighten up their intellectual
property rules
if that phase one deal is signed will it
be the beginning of the end of the trade
war
i took that question back to samaya
the americans are hugely ambitious for
for the kinds of changes that they would
want
from the chinese but those ambitions i
don't think will be reflected
in the preliminary phase one deal
the chinese government wants its economy
to do well and wants its citizens to
to get richer to the extent that the
americans persist in demanding these
big changes to the chinese economy
it's going to be really difficult to get
a deal
even if there is a phase one deal there
will be a lot of issues still to be
resolved
but there's more to the trade war than
just tariffs america has also imposed
restrictions on some chinese firms
especially ones in the tech industry
we cannot allow any other country to
out-compete the united states in this
powerful
industry of the future specifically over
one
chinese company huawei can offer cheaper
prices because they are heavily
subsidized by the chinese government
we've made another film that looks
closely at huawei and why the west is
worried about it
it includes a rare interview with
huawei's ceo run zhang fei
meiguo chi sensei
and we looked into how these tensions
will impact american industries
already dependent on huawei technology
the biggest
issue i think with all of this political
turmoil surrounding the huawei name is
uncertainty you can watch the huawei
film right now by clicking on the link
opposite
if you want to learn more about the
trade war you can click the other link
where you'll find
all the research we used to make this
film as well as other articles you've
written including a special report by
david rennie
as always if you liked what you saw hit
that subscribe button